where are we is what labour asks ten
years of austerity were in this position
now the obr has said that were in all
likelihood going to go into recession
this year
well good morning k and what I'd say is
but it's because of the decisions we've
made over the past few years our public
finances are in a in a good position the
foundations of our economy is strong
that I was able yesterday to say that I
will do what it takes to help get our
economy through the immediate challenges
coronavirus and outlined what I think is
a bold and comprehensive package to help
do that it reminds us of the importance
of having responsible management of the
economy so when things like this come
our way we can respond in in scale to
the challenge they present and that's
what yesterday was about we spent 10
years you know people let's see if
people I can identify with this at home
we spent 10 years trying to get our
household budget back in order we
finally managed to do that and now we're
going mad on the credit card no
absolutely not we are we all still have
very responsible management of public
finances if you look at what the
projections show that they show that we
have stayed within the fiscal rules that
we set out in our manifesto and
yesterday's budget was about delivering
on our promises which means that we
absolutely don't borrow for day-to-day
spending on on a forward basis and that
we do take advantage of the very low
interest rates that we're seeing at the
moment to borrow to invest in things
like infrastructure whether that's road
rail broadband and the reason we do that
is because that will drive up our
long-term growth our long-term
productivity create more jobs that are
better paid and that's actually what the
Office of Budget Responsibility talked
about yesterday as well they said that
that our long-term investment would do
exactly that and raise all long-term
productivity that to me is a sensible
plan you know that we it's massive
amounts of borrowing and it is a very
real threat to those fiscal rules you
also know that it's the biggest big
giveaway since 1992 you know even bigger
than what Gordon Brown got up to and
he's faced a lot of criticism for that
reason may yesterday in the House of
Commons said you're spending money
that's not ours and future generations
are gonna have to pay for it
well actually we're not borrowing for
day-to-day spending that's what our
fiscal rule said and if you if you look
in the third year of the forecast which
is the target year for our fiscal rules
they show a surplus so it means that we
are spending less than we collect in tax
receipts on our day to day spending and
debt over the forecast period it's
forecast to be lower at the end of the
Parliament than it is today so that to
me does show responsible economic
management but because of the decisions
we've made we can invest in public
services that's what I outlined
yesterday and I and I do make absolutely
no apology for the strong response in
the immediate term to tackling the
challenge of coronavirus I think that's
the right thing to do to support our
public services to support vulnerable
people and to support our small
businesses to make sure that they can
bridge through this difficult period
that protects people's jobs and means we
can emerge stronger at the other side
okay so not borrowing for day-to-day
spending does that include coronavirus
we will this year do everything it takes
to deal with the immediate challenge
that's absolutely the right thing to do
that's the right that's the right
economic response are the forecasts if
that's what's required that's what we
will do that that is the right thing to
do because the immediate challenge that
we face because of the credit virus will
have a significant impact on our economy
and I think the right decision in the
short term is to provide that support to
the NHS as they provide support to
vulnerable people who are affected or
can't work during this period and also
crucially to protect their jobs by
easing the cash flow burdens on small
business that was the package of
measures that we outlined yesterday but
that's in the short-term in the
medium-term you do need to have
responsible management of the public
finances which is why the plan I set out
yesterday does do that and ensures the
debt over the course of the parliament
is is falling so we are borrowing for
day to day spending as far as
coronavirus is concerned just to clarify
on that what preparations is Parliament
making for when we move into the next
phase of dealing with Co vid 19 later on
today
are you asking about Parliament as a
place of work are you asking about the
government
well Parliament is just like any other
organization we take advice from public
health England the health secretary made
a statement about that in Parliament
yesterday our plan very much is to carry
on we have an emergency piece of
legislation that we want to get through
to put in place various measures to help
us deal with coronavirus that's an
important piece of business that we will
turn to next week as as was news
yesterday certain people have been
affected directly by coronavirus and
there were getting the advice from
public health England who were doing the
contact tracing that they do to see
who's had contact with those people do
the testing as required the same way
they would do anywhere else in the
country and that contact close contact
is defined as spending about 15 minutes
within two metres of the person affected
but that work is going on now okay but
is it the right thing to do for
Parliament to continue to sit we've
heard from the United States President
Trump is raining back on his public
engagements and other engagements as
well he you know he's a senior political
figure he needs to keep well we've seen
what's happened as far as the cabinet
the cabinet is concerned and more junior
members that at least to look as though
they've come down with Kovich 19 we need
our senior politicians to be well is the
Palace of Westminster the right place
for them at the moment
well we take all our decisions based on
the advice of the chief medical officer
our chief scientific officer will make
the right decisions at the right time at
the moment there they are telling us
that the best thing for all of us
including parliamentarians to do is to
wash our hands for 20 seconds on a very
regular basis but that said we've also
said we're we're gonna try and can
contain this virus but it is likely that
it will spread beyond that and if we do
move into that phase we outlined a
series of steps we might have to take
last week in the action plan and as you
know as and when it's appropriate to
make those decisions we will do so and
that might mean some changes in how we
all work protecting the most vulnerable
but as I said we're not there yet but we
we will always be guided by the science
when we make these decisions still happy
for your youngsters to go to school yes
again the medical advice is very clear
but that's not something that they're
advising at the moment we outlined the
things that are likely to be considered
last week in the action action plan but
as I said at each step of this will be
guided by the science will make the
right decision at the right time and in
all cases what we're trying to do is to
find things which have maximum clinical
impact at least social cost but again
the Prime Minister the health secretary
the cabinet we're guided by the advice
that we're getting and we'll make those
decisions as we go through this together
have you had a coronavirus chest yet no
but because I haven't been in contact
with anybody from public health England
who provide the advice have not required
me to have parchment 80% of people who
carry the coronavirus show no signs or
symptoms you're in charge of the purse
strings you're deciding where the money
goes we need you as a nation to be well
surely the responsible thing to do is to
have a test it takes seconds well we
take all our advice from public health
England they know exactly who's who's
had coronavirus who's been exposed
who's that risk and they provide one of
your colleagues one of your colleagues
had coronavirus had Co vid 19 she was a
Health Minister right yeah okay so so
for example in that case as I said that
the close proximity to that person would
be defined as having been within 2
metres of them for about 15 minutes
obviously that's not something that I've
done otherwise I would have been
contacted by public health England and
had the contact testing they're doing
this all around the country they're very
good at it they're advised by the chief
scientific officer and the chief medical
officer they're doing all the work you
would expect them to do and whenever
it's appropriate for me anyone else to
have that testing will of course have it
but the right thing now is for people to
to wash their hands regularly for 20
seconds and and we as the government
will make the right decisions at the
right time guided by the science that is
the right thing to do okay you need to
reassure people watching the programme
today mr. suno you know they've gone
past let's wash our hands for 20 seconds
they've got all of that singing god save
the queen while they wash their hands
people are dying I am sure that you've
been in contact with people for more
than 15 minutes who have potentially got
kovat 19 and you don't know because
they're not showing symptoms why not
just have a test
yeah Kate with the greatest respect I'll
take my advice from the chief scientific
on for the chief medical officer and
public health England but when you talk
about reassurance it is important that
people wash their hands regularly it's
fine if people are bored that we're
saying that because actually that is the
best thing for people to do but we've
said that we are trying to do our best
to contain this virus but it is lightly
a little spread and if we do move into
that next phase there will be other
things that people need to do we set
some of those out last week as I said
and as we go down this phase whether
it's the prime minister the chief
medical officer we will of course make
those conversations transparent and
public with the British people about
further things that we might all need to
do but I wouldn't belittle it at all
washing your hands for 20 second is
right now the best thing that all of us
can do it's good to talk to your
Chancellor a busy day ahead for you
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thanks a lot